[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا مع ارقام ميزانيه
العامه الجديد حيث جاءت الارقام كالتالي
ايرادات عند تريليون و130 مليار ريال فيما
بلغت النفقات عند تريليون
و14 مليار ريال وفائض متوقعه بقيمه 16
مليار ريال وهذا الفائض يشكل حوالي صفر
فاصل 4% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
للمملكه ولكن ماذا عن الارقام المحققه
للعام الجاري 2022 ايرادات الفعليه وصلت
الى تريليون و200 و34 مليار ريال مقارنه
مع المقدر عند وضع الميزانيه بقيمه
تريليون و45 مليار ريال ان فقط ايضا جاءت
اعلى من التقديرات الاوليه عند تريليون
و132 مليار ريال مقارنه مع التقديرات
الاوليه بانفاق
955 مليار ريال ولكن الفائض ارتفع الى 102
مليار ريال وهو اول فائط تحققه ميزانيه
المملكه منذ عام
2013 الان دعونا نتوقف قليلا مع تطور
العجز والفائض من اعوام 2016 الى 2025 كما
قلنا اخر قائد حققته ميزانيه المملكه كان
عام
2013 عند 180 مليار ريال منذ 2014 بدانا
بترجيع العجز وبلغ اعلى مستوياته عام 2015
عند 367 مليار ريال وفي عام 2016 كان
العجز عند حوالي 300 مليار تناقص العرش
تدريجيا حتى 2019 ولكن سنه الجائحه عام 20
20 سجل العجز قفزه قبل ان يعود للتراجع في
2000 و 2001
العام الحالي عدنا للفوائد بقوه حيث وصل
الفائض الى 102 مليار ريال ما يشكل 2.6%
من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي والتوقعات
للمدى المتوسط هو باستمرار تسجيل هذه
الفوائد التي ستصل بحسب التوقعات الى 71
مليار ريال لعام 2025
بالتاكيد فوائد عام 2022 تاثرت بشكل واضح
بالارتفاع القوي الذي شاهدناه في اسعار
النفط لاحظوا انه بدانا العام الماضي عام
2021 عند متوسط سعر لخام برنت بحدود ال 55
دولار للبرميل بعد عام صعب للغايه يعني
اسواق الطاقه في 2020 مع انتشار بالطبع
جاء احد همم كورونا ارتفعت الاسعار بشكل
تدريجي منذ مطلع 2000 21 حتى سجلنا قمه
ليه متوسط سعر براند عندها 117 ونصف دولار
البرميل في يونيو هذا العام طبعا في ظل
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا ثم بدات الاسعار
بتراجع ولكنها كانت عند معدلات ال 90
دولار خلال سبتمبر واكتوبر نوفمبر هنا
اكيد عم نتحدث عن متوسط سعر برانده الشهري
ولكن لا ننسى انه اسعار النفط وصلت العام
الحالي الى 139 دولار خلاله التداولات
اليوميه
سياسه الدين العام تماشت خلال هذه السنوات
مع التطورات في تحضير الميزانيه العامه لو
واحد انه منذ العام 2015 كانت الدين العام
عند حوالي 142 مليار ريال مشكل حينها حدود
6% من الناتج المحلي ازدادت المديونيه ضمن
خطه لوزاره الماليه لضمان بناء علاقه مع
اسواق الدين تسمح للمملكه بالاستدانا في
اوقات الحاجه وايضا في اوقات الرخاء محفظه
الدين العام تصل اليوم الى
985 مليار ريال لتقارب ال 25% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي علما بانه مكتب اداره
الدين قام في العام الجاري بالسداد المبكر
للقروض دوليه تستحق في السنوات القليله
المقبله لاداره المحفظه بشكل افضل ومن
المتوقع ان يتراجع الدين العام الى 951
مليار ايه ثلاثه ونصف بالمئه من الناتج
المحلي مالي في العام المقبل ولكن كيف تمت
اداره محفظه الدين العام السعودي في
السنوات القليله الماضيه بين الاقراض
والسداد من الواضح انه عام 2020 عام كرونه
قد شهد حجم الاقتراض الاكبر عند 220 مليار
ريال بين بينما شهد العام الذي يليه عام
2021 اكبر حجم سداد بلغ 73 مليار ريال مع
العلم ان الاقتراض كان دائما اكثر من ضعف
حجم السداد الا في العام الحالي 2022
نلاحظ انه تقليص الفجوه بين السداد
والاقتراف
يعني نتحدث الان عن النمو الاقتصادي
للسعوديه في العام الجاري كان هو الاسرع
بين دول مجموعه العشرين بعد ان جاء عند
8.5% اعلى من التقديرات السابقه التي كانت
عند 8% تقارن هذه الارقام بوتيره اضعف
للنمو في السنوات السابقه
وتقارن بانكماش اقتصادي بحدود الاربعه في
المئه في عام 2020 عندما اوقف فايروس
كورون الاقتصاد حول العالم مع العلم ان
نمو الاقتصاد غير النفطي تسارع هذا العام
ليلامس الست بالمائه وليفهم بقوه ايضا في
اجمالي النمو الاقتصادي ولكن النمو في
العام المقبل من المتوقع ان يتراجع بعض
الشيء وان يسجل واحد في المئه مدعوما بل
انشطه ليرتفع بعد ذلك الى
5.7 في العام 2024
واربعه ونصف المئه في العام 2025
لنقارن هذه الارقام بمجموعه من دول مجموعه
العشرين بحسب اخر تقديرات من صندوق النقد
الدولي والتي صدرت في اكتوبر الماضي الصين
مثلا نسب النمو المتوقع عندها
3.2% اليابان عند واحد فاصل سبعه في المئه
الهند 6.8 بالمئه تقديرات للسعوديه عند
7.6 للايه وهي اقل من تقديرات المملكه
روسيا انكباش بتلاقي فاصل اربعه في المئه
المانيا 1.5 فرنسا 2.5% وبريطانيا 3.6%
الولايات المتحده واحد فاصل سته في المئه
ولكن ما هي توقعات الصندوق لنمو الاقتصادي
لهذه الدول في العام المقبل تختلف الصوره
كليه ولكن التوقعات تبقى ايجابيه الاقتصاد
المملكه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
التضخم الان مشاهدينا في العام الجاري كان
بالطبع تحدي الاصعب للاقتصاد العالمي
والذي سبب تحول البنوك المركزيه للسياسات
النقديه المتشدده ولكن راينا فيها
ارتفاعات متتاليه وقويه للفوائد وهي
بدورها ايضا ما يساهم في افاق ركود
الاقتصاد العالمي السعوديه اتخذت اجراءات
لحمايه الاقتصاد من التضخم نتحدث بالطبع
هنا عن تثبيت اسعار الطاقه والنتيجه كانت
معدل تضخم من الادنى عالميا في العام 2022
عند 2.6
مع حتى التوقعات بتراجع مستويات التضخم
الى اثنين فاصل واحد في المئه في العام
المقبل كيف نقارن هذه الارقام ببقيه
العالم نعود لتقديرات صندوق النقد الدولي
للتضخم الصين عندها اثنين فاصله اثنين
بالمئه اليابان عندها اثنين بالمئه ولكن
لاحظوا كيف ترتفع للهند مثلا عند 6.9%
روسيا 14 تقريبا المانيا 2.5% فرنسا
5.8% بريطانيا فوق 9% والولايات المتحده
فوق الثمانيه في المئه
وقبل ان نتحول الى ضيوفنا لتحليل كل هذه
الارقام نتوقف مع توزيع ميزانيه العام
المقبل على ابرز القطاعات الصحه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه
189 مليار ريال الخدمات البلديه حوالي 63
مليار
التعليم 189 مليار ريال ما شفنا كثير فارق
عن ارقام العام 2022 القطاع العسكري كان
فيه نمو بالانفاق الى 259 مليار ريال ريال
تجهيزات الاساسيه والنقل كان فيها تراجعات
الاكبر في العام 2023 بالمقارنه مع 2022
وصلت النفقات عليها الى 34 مليار
[موسيقى]
مجاهدين ان اذهب الى الرياض مع مفردات
العربيه نادين هاني بالطبع تتابع ارقام
الميزانيه نادين اهلا وسهلا بك نادين يعني
الميزانيه بشكل عام عنا من شهر سبتمبر
ارقام التمهيديه وعندنا حتى ارقام اول
تسعه اشهر وبالتالي ما هي المفاجات التي
نراها في هذه الميزانيه التي تم الاعلان
عنها اليوم لانه في كثير من الارقام اصبحت
معروفه
لارا بالفعل ليس هناك من مفاجات كبيره بال
2003 ميزانيه 2023 بعض التعديلات عن
الميزانيه التمهيديه لتم الاعلان عنها
بنهايه تسعه اشهر الاولى من العام الحاليه
ربما شويه مفاجات بارقام 2022 المحققه
فعليا لانه فوق التوقعات الميزانيه
المجدوله مطلع العام والتمهيديه اللي تم
همم عمل ابديت على الارقام بنهايه سبتمبر
قبل ان اتحدث عن ملاحظات على هذه الارقام
اشاره لارا لانه في مؤتمر صحفي لمعالي
وزير الماليه محمد الجدعان ينعقد همم
حاليا بالفندق محل ما انا متواجده
وبالتالي سننقل ابرز ما ياتي كما انه خاصه
بمقابله خاصه للعربيه سنبثها بعد قليل
دعينا نتوقف عند الارقام لارا اذا اردنا
ان ننظر الى الايرادات اولا الافات نظري
اكيد انه الارادات المحققه اعلى بحوالي
200 مليار عن المجادله لماذا لانه اسعار
النفط كما ذكرتي كانت في هذه السنه متوسط
سعد النفط لهذه السنه كان 101 فاصل سبعه
دولار وانتاج المملكه بالمتوسط كان 10.6
مليون برميل في اليوم هلا دخلت حيزه تنفيذ
تخفيضات الانتاج بنوفمبر اللارا وهنا
السؤال للعام القادم هذا من المفترض انه
مع اسعار نفط اقل متوقع ان احنا هنشوف
الاسعار الحاليه اللي نفط فيها تراجع في
ظل مخاوف من ركود اقتصادي في ظل توقعات
بتراجع اسعار النفط وتراجع بالانتاج
مستغرب السيناريو الاساسي اللي هو تريليون
و 130 ملياردات متوقعه للعام القادم يعني
اقل 100 مليار عن المحقق بال220 هل كانوا
متحفظين بسعر نفط الموضوع بالميزانيه
دائما علامه استفهام وزاره الماليه لا
تصفح عن سعر النفط الذي تبني عليه
الميزانيه وبالتالي سنترقب التحليلات
المحللين اللي بيصدروا تقارير وبيعطونا ما
هو سعر النفط اللي برايه معتمد بالميزانيه
بالنسبه للفوائد المفاجاه لارا اكيد كانت
انه الفائض المتوقعه لل 2022 كان 90 مليار
الفائض المحقق 102 مليار اعلى من المتوقع
للعام القادم رفعوه ببعض الشيء كانه عم
يحكوا بتسعه مليار فاقد الان المتوقع هو
16 مليار فائض العام القادم
انه هيدا من قد ما في ارقام
لهذا العام تم رفعه من زمان على 8:30 2020
لانه لارا كم ذكرنا الارادات النفطيه همم
الموضوع اسعار النفط نعم ولكن ايضا في
مساهمه من قطاع غير النفطي راح اتحدث عنها
بس ارقام النمو تتراجع على ثلاثه فاصل
واحد بالمئه العام القادم لماذا لانه
البيت صار عليه يعني مجرد مرتفع على
الاقتصاد الجيزه فيه بثمانيه ونصف بالمئه
بالعام 2022 نحنا دايما من قارن سنويا
العام القادم من الصعب تراب لكي هل نسب
النمو القويه وبالتالي توقعات لثلاثه فاصل
واحد بالمئه النمو
هو ما عدا ما نتحدث عن 2.6% العام الحالي
انه ارقام حتى نمو جيده بالمقارنه مع
توقعات في ركود وانتماج في الاقتصادات
الكبرى
اكيد بصرنا عم نقارن مع بيس اكبر بكثير
يعني الجديد
8.5 انما بشكل كبير جدا فالبيستار عالي
بالتالي ثلاثه فاصل واحد بالمئه يكون
مقبول جدا من هذا البيت هلا موضوع التضخم
ايضا ملفات ملاحظه هنا هي ارقام التضخم
المتدنيه المتوقعه للعام القادم يعني
سجلنا بال22 فاصل سته بالمئه بالوقت اللي
اخر ارقام الولايات المتحده 7.7 لانه
اسعار الطاقه مدعومه بالسعوديه كون
يتوقعون اثنين فاصل واحد بالمئه فقط تضخم
العام القادم معناتها في استمرار بالدعم
الذي هو قائم يعني هذا سؤال لم يتسنى لدي
توجيهه لوزير الماليه بس همم واضح انه
مكون مستويات التضخم المتوقع متدنيه بهذا
الشكل معناته في استمرار بالدعم اللي كان
قائم ب 2000 و 2020 همم لا لا لم تتحدث
بالبرزنتيشن قبل قليل عن تقسيم الارادات
ما بين النفطيه وغير نفطيه اذا نظرنا الى
ايرادات المحققه لل 2022 عم نتحدث عن
تريليون 234 مليار ريال من اصل 842 مليار
اللي هي الايرادات النفطيه بشكل 68% من
اجمالي الارادات غير النفطيات 392 مليار
ريال تمثل 32% من اجمالي الايرادات هذا
بعام اسعار النفط كانت مرتفعه فيه
والانتاج مرتفعه ما يعني نجاح تنويع مساعد
تنويع الاقتصاد للذكر بسنوات سابقه كان
لارادات النفطيه تشكل حوالي 90% من ارادات
المملكه بالنسبه للدين ملاحظته انه همم
ما في يبدو انه ليس هناك من توجه
لاستخدام الفوائد اللي هي 102 مليار ريال
هذا العام لن يتم استخدامها للسداد الدين
لماذا لانه 2022 صار في عمليه السباقيه
سداد مبكر لديون اعاده تمويل ديون ستستحق
في المستقبل ولكن الملفت هو انه اصبحت
استيدانا اكثر محليا منها عالميا اذا
نظرنا الى تقسيم الدين داخلي مقارنه مع
خارجي دين الخارجي يمثل فقط 37% من اجمال
الدين الدين المحلي 63% ما يعني همم
اصدارات محليه همم تستبدل الاصدارات
الخارجيه هلا هنا هذا بيطرح سؤال على
القطاع المصري في لانه احنا بنعرف انه
السايبر مرتفع بالتالي هل تتحمل البنوك
المزيد من الاصدارات الدين المحليه همم
هذا سؤال اكيد
الميزانيه انه الاقراض
عفوا العراق فايبر ثلاثه اشهر قول تايم
هاي نظرنا اليه
منذ قليل
مستويات قياسيه هذا بيطرح سؤال عندك
مستويات الاقراض لارا بحسب بيان الميزانيه
ارتفعت لحد اند اب سبتمبر نهايه سبتمبر
مرتفعه
14.5% الودائع لا تنمو بنفس نسب الاقراض
وبالتالي هذا يفسر ضغط على سايبر انما لفت
نظري انه ببيان الميزانيه بيقولوا انه
القروض المشكوك بتحصيله المنبر
اقل من مكانه ما قبل رائحه كوفد وهذا ملفت
لانه عندما ترتفع اسعار الفائده عاده جوده
الاصول بالقطاعه المصري هذا ملفت انه
نهايه سبتمبرز منخفضه بالقطاع المصري فيه
ولكن اكيد سنرى هترتفع بالفترات القادمه
همم بالنسبه للايرادات غير النفطيه
الضرائب شكل 315 مليار ريال من اجمالي
الايرادات الهجري اليوم و234 مليار ريال
ضرائب فيها ارتفاع رح ارجع اتحدث عنها
بالنسبه لل 2023 بس ايضا بما اني عم بتحدث
عن ايرادات 2022 المحققه لفت نظري انه
شماله الايرادات النفطيه مع
العوائد على استثمارات الحكومه سموها قدر
رافينيوز يعني تحت الارض الرافينيوز حاطين
المبلغ 919 مليار ريال هذا يحتوي على 842
مليار ريال ايرادات النفطيه والباقي لحد
ما نوصل ل 919 هي همم العوائد على
الاستثمارات فاذن هذا امر ملفت بالاضر
نوصل على نقطه شائكه خلينا نسميها لانه ما
عندي تفسير لها
احتياط الحكومه لدى سامه همم الميزانيه
بتقول انه احتياطي الحكومي لدى سامه بلاغ
بنهايه ال 2022 394 مليار
اغتيال من 347 مليار بنهايه 2021 يعني
مرتفع الا احتياطي 50 مليار تقريبا خلال
العام ملفت انه الميزانيه بيان الميزانيه
بيقول انه بنهايه 2023 رح يرتفع الاحتياطي
ل 399 مليار ريال يعني فقط ارتفاع بخمسه
مليار ريال هذا مفارقه مع ما قاله لوزير
الماليه عندما تحدثت اليه رح نسمع
المقابله بعد قليل سالته كيف سيتم استخدام
الفوائد اللي هي 102 مليار لهذا العام
اللي ما في سداد دين معظم المبالغ ستذهب
الى الاحتياطي ومن بعد نحول من الاحتياط
الى الصناديق الحكوميه اللي هي البيئه
احسن صندوق الاستثمارات العامه وصندوق
التنميه الوطنيه الاندياف واا ايضا
للمشاريع لدعم المشاريع الاستراتيجيه
للدوله سالته ما هي المشاريع الاستراتيجيه
المفسره بالمقابله بس تحليلي انه اذا كان
وزير الماليه عم بقول انه تحويل جزء كبير
من الاحتياط الى همم احتياطي الحكومه لدى
ساعه والارقام بس عم بتقول 399 مليار
بنهايه السنه 2023 معناتها تذهب الى
احتياطي الحكومه ربما تستخدم لتدعيم البي
اي اف والان دي اف سؤال مفتوح هذا بحاجه
نحن الى الاجابه عليه موضوع الانفاق
الراسمالي وهنا ملفت لانه انا سالت وزير
الماليه انه امم اليوم البي اي اف عم ينفق
على مشاريع ضخمه هل كله انفاق
حكومي قال لي لا في حوالي 30 ل 40 مليار
من الميزانيه يذهب الى المشاريع هلا لفت
نظري انه الكاف اكس ال الانفاق الراس مال
نهايه 2022 مرتفع 30% عن العام السابق الى
151 مليار بالعام 2023 فقط يرتفع بس ثلاثه
ونصف الى 1057 مليار ربما فرونت لودينج
الكابرس يعني صار معظم بال220 وما في
الكثير منه بال 2000
و23 هذه ابرز النقاط لارا همم
رح نرجع نعود معكم الفاينانس تفضل يا ليلى
همم ختم نقطه سريعه لانه يجب ان نذهب الى
الضيوف وسوف نعود اليك بعد قليل نديم ولكن
نقطه سريعه
نقطه سريعه اللي هي تكاليف التمويل يلهي
تكاليف تمويل زين من المفطرات بال23
بلغ 39 مليار ريال مرتفعه 22% عن العام هي
المجادله لل23 متوقع ان ترتفع ب 22% على
2020 وهذا بيعود وبياخذنا لارا لموضوع
ارتفاع اسعار الفوائد العالميه راح تدفع
ترفع تكاليف تمويل رغم انه بالنسبه لاكبر
من القرود وربما اكثر من 80% من القرود هي
فائده ثابته وليست فائده متغيره نادين انت
باقيه معنا نحلل كل ذلك ما عدد كبير من
الضيوف معك ومعي ولكن دعوني الان ارحب
بضيفي من الرياض مازن السديري رئيس
الابحاث في الراجحي كابتل مازن اهلا وسهلا
بك مازن كثير من الامور المهمه يجب ان
نسال عنها في هذه الميزانيه وربما السؤال
الاول دائما على اي اسعار من النفط برايك
احتسبت هذه المي هي لانه نحنا بنعرف انه
تم تغيير طريقه احتساب سعر النفط في
الميزانيه من العام الماضي يحتسب على
اسعار استرشاديه على بيانات تاريخيه للنفط
وعلى اساسه تبنى النفقات برايك انت على اي
سعر نفط بنيت ميزانيه 2023
وتحياتي للاخوه المشاركين في الحلقه
الليله
بنيت اسعار 23 على سعر 78$ حسب تقديراتنا
يعني على البترول 10.7 صحيح المملكه نزلت
الانتاج لكن الرقم ثابت يعني الرقم ممكن
انه تحس انه طلب العلم يرتفع نسبيا للعشره
فاصله سبعه فاخذناه على هذا المتوسط وعلى
اسعار 78$
متوقع انه بالتالي يكون بحدود 65% من
الدخل البترولي للمملكه همم
65 يكون بترولي حقيقي غير بترولي من عام
اا من العام القادم 23
والحقيقه توقعنا السنه هذه الفائض كانه
متوقعين 116,000,000 جالس سبب جاء بعدين
التخفيض يعني احنا حطينا ال16 كان قبل
التخفيف تذكرين لما اصدرهم البيان من
شهرين عن التوقعات همم السنه كلها كان قبل
قرار
انتاجيه فكنا متوقعين الفاضل 90 واضح انه
كنا رايحين رقم 90 رقم وتحفظ انه هيكون
اعلى منه
و16 تقريبا
ورقم جيد الحمد لله
ااا يعني الايرادات المتوقعه في العام
المقبل ليست بعيده كثيره عن الارقام
الفعليه لارادات العام 2022 رغم انه
الصوره اكثر ضبابيه في العام المقبل خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالرقود الاقتصادي وبالتالي
ممكن نشوف تراجعات اكبر على اسعار النفط
ما رايك هل تعتبر بانه هذا السيناريو
متفائل نوعا ما يلي عم نشوفه
واقعيه
السعر البترول اللي هالسنه تقريبا كم
متوسط
لذلك
الرافع او الدخله الماليه السنه اعلى من
السنه القادمه اوكي المتوقع للسنه القادمه
اسعار البترول في ضعف الطلب هذا موجود في
العالم يعني اعتقد ان الاسوء الاسود خلف
انا وضع الصين الان قبل الانفتاح اكثر ما
هو مقابل الاغلاق
في امريكا الحقيقه صحيح انه في ضعاف قاعد
يصير للطلب رفع اسعار الفائده لكن في
اشياء ايضا تاثر على العرض قويه مثلا
النفط الروسي الغرامات اللي عليه راح تسحب
النفط الروسي من المصافي الامريكيه
والروسيه والاوروبيه
النفط الايراني لم يعد فشلت مفاوضاته
المخزونات الامريكيه نزلت تجاريه
والحكوميه الفيدراليه نزلت لاقل مستوى من
34 سنه هذا الارقام ظهرت اليوم اربعه نفطر
كنت تكلمت معك فين النفط الصخري حجم
الرافع الماليه اللي عليه راح تجعل ضغوطات
على التوسع يعني اسعار البترول هتساعد على
تقليص الدين اكثر من انه يرفع انتاجها
يعني عندنا مشكله تطلع لك وين المشكله
التسعار البترول
صحيح في مشكله في الطلب هذه قديمه يعني من
شهور الواضحه المشكله هي في الفايبر ماركت
الفايبر ماركت الصناديق التحول كميه
السيوله اللي انخفضت في العالم بين
الاسواق والمضاربين هي اللي الحقيقه مغلقه
لما تذكرين نزلت مجرد اشاعه نزلت اسعار
البترول خمسه دولار
اوبك تحسنت الاسعار في السوق الفايبر
ماركترون كده هكذا ارى الامر يعني العرض
والطلب واضح حتى اجواء الكساد ما راح تكون
مقلقه في مشاكل عارض ايضا وفي مشاكل
ستلايت تخلق توازن مطلوب لكن المشكله هي
اعتقد في البيبر ماركت اغلب الرزقنا لذلك
توضح للسوق حقيقه التوازن
ارجو منك ان تبقى معي مازن اتوجه الان الى
ضيف في ايضا دكتور نايف الغيث كبير
الاقتصاديين في بنك الرياض دكتور نايف
اهلا وسهلا بك ايضا نفس السؤال الك كم
بتقدروا اسعار النفط في هذه الميزانيه وهل
تعتبر بانه الايرادات
المقدره للعام 2023 هي ارادات معقوله ام
متحفظه ما رايك
بالنسبه للايرادات الايرادات
المستقبليه
على التوقعات التاريخيه
بالنسبه للايرادات
المستقبليه بسعر البترول الان مثلا عندنا
زينه مازن همم نهايه السنه الهجريه
المتوقع في السنه القادمه على 90
فمتماشع جدا الايرادات
سيناريو البيس همم لاين سيناريو مع الفرقه
الثالثه ال- ال- اللي يتم تحديدها
وزي ما تفضل لك مازن على ال ال
تحديد السعر بترول ناحيه النفقات النفقات
اللي هي تعتمد على اسعار البترول جزء منها
راح يعتمد
تقديراتنا في بنك الرياض مقاربه على 80$
اللي هي تمت بناءها في الميزانيه
في ما يتعلق بما انو عم نتحدث باسعار
النفط فيما يتعلق باسعار النفط تحديدا على
ما اظن جولد منساكس كان قال ااا مؤخرا انه
اكيد كان الامر الاساسي اللي عم باكثر على
اسعار النفط موضوع الاغلاقات في الصين
الان مع الحديث انه عوده الحركه او نشاط
الى طبيعتها وبشكل سريع جود من ساعه كان
عم بقول انه هذا راح ياخذ مثل تشديد
بالسوق النفطيه وممكن ان يضيف الى سعر
برنت في وقت قصير 20 دولار هل انتم
بتتفقوا مع هذه التوقعات
في الان جانبين جانب زياده في الطلب من
جهه الانفتاح الصيني في
خصوصا البداويه يتسهلون من ناحيه الزيرو
الان في تقليل من الشده بالنسبه للجانب
الصيني بالجانب الاخر التوفيق توقعات
كبيره
في الولايات المتحده
وهذه يعني راح تنقص كميه الدمان بنفس
الوقت عندنا في زياده بالدمام
فراح يكون في بنات الصراحه هو هارد او ولد
يوم النكثير همم
مثل هذه السنه بالعكس همم ممكن راح نشوف
اسعار البترول في المستوى 90 يعني
90 يعني
دكتور نايف دعني اتوقف عند الايرادات غير
النفطيه
الايرادات غير النفطيه كان فيها ايرادات
الضرائب تحديدا اتحدث عنها في العام
الماضي 2022 كان فيها بعض التراجع تراجع
بسيط رغم النمو بالاقتصاد السعودي ب8.5%
كنا بنتوقع زياده بالايرادات الضريبيه
يبدو لانه في العام 2021 كان في تحسيلات
غير اعتياديه وبالتالي اذا لم ناخذها في
عين الاعتبار كانت الارادات الضريبيه اكبر
من ذلك ولكن سؤالي انا للعام المقبل ما هي
توقعاتكم في ظل همم
الاقتصاد السعودي هل ممكن نشوف انه تباته
لانه في جايه من البيت يعني كثير عاقله
بال22 هل ممكن نشوف تباته اضافي
بالايرادات من الضرائب
الان عندنا الميزانيه حدد تقديرات 2000 23
سنه القادمه
[موسيقى]
235 هذه واضح ان فيه زياده
كبيره راح تكون جايه
السنه القادمه في نزول في سعر القويه
السنه
اللي بعدها ما راح يعني راح تكون مثلا
زياده الواضح من هذا بالنسبه همم
ولكن يجب ان نذهب الان الى المؤتمر الصحفي
لوزير الماليه محمد الجنوبي
لمباركه خادم الحرمين الشريفين ايد الله
لاعلان الميزانيه في جلسه مجلس الوزراء
والتي رات
ما تشهده المملكه ولله الحمد من
تنامي متسارع وتحقيق ااه عديد من
المستهدفات همم تحت رؤيه المملكه 2030
واستراتيجيات ومشاريع متعدده سواء
انقطاعيه ومكانيه
واستمعنا وشاهدنا ااا قبل قليل ايضا ما
ذكر
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء بمناسبه صدور
ميزانيه
بخصوص ما يتعلق
بالانجازات التي تحققت خلال العام 20 22
وهي نتيجه لعمل دؤوب وجهد كبير جدا
تم خلال سنوات همم
سابقا بدانا نشاهد نتائجها ولله الحمد
فيما تحقق من انجازات على المستوى الماليه
العامه لعام 22
وما هو مخطط باذن الله تعالى في سنه 23
تحدث
عن عديد من الاستراتيجيات التي تم بدات
تنفيذها
وعن عديد من المستندات التي تم تحقيقها
وساذكر على سبيل المثال ااا الجزئيتين
مهمه كان سموه ولا يزال يرعاه بشكل حديث
الاولى الاسكان
وتحقيق انجازات سابقا لوقتها فيما يتعلق
بنسبه ملكيه
المواطنين للسكن
ولله الحمد تحقق انجاز مميز بارتفاع
النسبه بدايه الرؤيه من 42% الى ان وصلنا
الى ما وصلنا الى الان ايضا مشاركه وتحدث
سمو عن اهميه الموارد ودور المواطن وهو
العنصر الاساسي
التي تعتمد عليه المملكه في ما يحدث من
تطور ومن هذا تحدث سمو ايضا عن تمكين
المراه
واستطعنا من خلال العديد من الاستراتيجيات
والمبادرات والمشاريع من الوصول الى
مستهدف كان مخطط له في 2030 تحقق نهايه
العام الحمد وصلنا الى
35.7% من مشاركه المراه في سوق العمل من
نسب كانت قلبي كثيره اقل من النصف في
السابق تحدث ايمن عن عدد من استراتيجيات
ما في ذلك استراتيجيات التي اطلقت مؤخرا
الاستراتيجيه الصناعيه التي تستهدف الى
رفع مستوى
القطاع الصناعي
استغلال الممكنات التي وفرتها الحكومه
فيما يتعلق برفع مستوى الناتج المحلي
رفع مستوى مدخلات الوطنيه في المشاريع
الحكوميه والمشاريع التي ينفذها صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه والشركات التابعه له
شهيدنا انجازات واضحه جدا فيما يتعلق بسوق
العمل
من تحقيق انخفاض في نسبه البطاله الى
مستويات
لمشاهده خلال العشرين سنه الماضيه
شهدنا كثير ايضا من
الانجازات فيما يتعلق بتمكين القطاع الخاص
همم تمكين المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه اعلن
مؤخرا عن انشاء بنك المنشات الصغيره
والمتوسطه وهناك العديد همم من ما تحقق
ولله الحمد يتحدث عنه صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان باسهاب في كلمه بثت
او بيان صحفي بث قبل قليل
فيما يتعلق
بالارقام ولا التوقعات الاقتصاديه
ساتحدث باختصار ومن ثم ساترك المجال همم
الاسئله
سنتحدث عن النمو الاقتصادي في المدى
المتوسط ومن ثم اتحدث عن ارقام الميزانيه
وبعض المؤشرات الاساسيه
لسنه 22
والمتوقع لسنه 23
همم
[موسيقى]
في ما يتعلق
بالمؤشرات الاقتصاديه اعتقد ويمكن امامنا
في الشاشه
تكلم صاحب السمو الملكي اييي عن توقعات
النمو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بنهايه هذا
العام من المتوقع ان تصل الى
8.5%
وهذا الرقم يمكن يجب ان نتوقف عنده قليلا
لما تحدثنا في مثل هذا الوقت تقريبا عام
الماضي كنا نتوقع تقريبا سبعه فاصله اربعه
في المئه
وكان الكثير يتحدثون عن الحكومه متفائله
في الرقم هذا
تفاعل
ال ال المجتمع الدولي مع ما يحدث في
المملكه رفع توقعاتهم المملكه هي الوحيده
على مستوى دول مجموعه العشرين التي تمر
رفع التوقعاتها التوقعات المويه الاقتصادي
من صندوق النقل الدولي مرتين خلال العام
الحالي وحتى مع ذلك وصلوا الى 7.6 ااه
اعلى من توقعاتنا الاساسيه لكن لم يصلوا
الى همم
فعلا تحقق على ارض الواقع وهو ثمانيه
فاصله خمسه وهو الاعلى من بين دول مجموعه
ال20
المطمئن بالنسبه لنا ايضا هو محل تركيزنا
محل تركيزنا هو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
للنشاط القطاع الخاص
وهو محور رؤيه المملكه 20 30 من تنويع
الاقتصاد
وتمكين القطاع الخاص
ما نتوقع ان ننتهي فيه هذا العام هو
تقريبا 5.9%
نمو انشطه القطاع الخاص ناتج المحلي
الاجمالي واعتقد هذا رقم مهم جدا لانه
سنشاهد خلال سنوات القادمه
استراتيجيات التي تم تفعلها خلال الاربع
خمس سنوات همم الماضي الناتج المحلي
الاسمي همم لاول مره في تاريخ المملكه
يتخطى حاجز التريليون
دولار
نتوقع باذن الله ان ننتهي هذا العام
بثلاثه فاصله تسعه خمسه سبعه ترليون ريال
العام القادم
الارقام امامنا
3,869 تريليون وفي عام 24 نتوقع ان يكون
الناتج المحلي الاسم تقريبا في حدود ثلاثه
فاصله 49
ريال باذن الله تعالى
في المدى المتوسط واعتقد هذا
جزء من رحله
بداناها من بدايه رؤيه المملكه 2030 ان
الخطط
واضحه جدا استراتيجيات واضحه جدا وتنفيذها
من ثلاث اربع سنوات بدا الان ياتي ثمار
نتوقع
همم الاستثمار ينمو ببيوتيرا
وشاهدنا خلال العام الحالي نمو الاستثمار
من القطاع الخاص بنسبه تجاوز ال20%
مقارنه بالعالم الماضي
بالاستراتيجيات في ذلك استراتيجيات
الاستثمار الوطنيه للاستثمار برنامج شريك
البرامج المتعلقه والمشاهده الصغيره
والمتوسطه ان تتوقع ينمو مشاركه القطاع
الخاص باذن الله تعالى ايضا شاهدنا جهود
كبيره جدا تبذلها الحكومه استباقيه
للتعامل مع الازمات
ولا اعتقد انه احتاج ان اؤكد على
النجاحات اللي تمت
بتفاعل كبير جدا بين الحكومه والمواطنين
والقطاع الخاص اثناء جائحه
مشاهد ايضا شيء مشابه لها تم خلال العام
هذا بتفاعل الحكومه مع التضخم العالمي
والتضخم على مستوى العالم المتوسط حسب
تقديرات صندوق النقد الدولي تقريبا 8.8
ااااه
على مستوى الاقتصاد العالمي
استطاعت الحكومه السباقيه ولو نتذكر في
العام الماضي تقريبا في منتصف العام
الماضي عندما ااا احسست المملكه وفقا
لتقديرات الاقتصاديين المميزين صراحه اللي
يعملون في الحكومه ان الاجراءات التي
اتخذها عدد من الدول في ما يتعلق بدعم
اقتصاداتها وتوفير سيوله عاليه جدا في
اقتصادات بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
وغيرها من الدول سينتج عنها تسارع في
مستوى التضخم
اتخذت الحكومه قرار في شهر سبعه من العام
الماضي بوضع سقف على اسعار الوقود في
الاقتصاد السعودي
ولونه لاحظ ان المسبب الرئيسي للتضخم على
مستوى العالم كان اسعار الطاقه
فكبح جماح التضخم في المملكه بقرار
الحكومه من العام الماضي شاهدنا اثاره
العام الماضي وهذه السنه في مستويات تضخم
منخفضه نسبيا ومنخفضا بشكل كبير جدا عن ما
نشاهده في العالم التضخم مستويات السعوديه
بنهايه هذا العام اتوقع ان يصل الى
الاثنين فاصله سته ومن ثم ينزل للسنه
القادمه الى مستويات اقل قد تصل الى اثنين
فاصله واحد
بالمئه همم الممكنات اللي وفرتها الحكومه
ايضا
للقطاع الخاص وتكلمنا يمكن العام الماضي
عندما سالت عن
الارادات غير النفطيه همم ارتفاع التكاليف
عن القطاع الخاص همم ذكرته بشكل واضح ان
الحكومه الان تستهدف نمو الاقتصاد ونمو
الاقتصاديه يعني نمو الارادات ولا نستهدف
فقط نمو الايرادات لوحدها
فاتخذنا مبادرات متعدده خلال العام هذا من
من ضمنها تخفيض بعد الرسوم الجمركيه من
ضمنها تخفيض
وتقسيط حتى بعض
الاعباء الماليه على القطاع الخاص ما في
ذلك المقابل المالكي كان يدفع مقدما لمده
12 شهر الان سمحنا انه يدفع على اقساط
ربعيه
وتسارعت وتيره دفع مستحقات القطاع الخاص
من قبل الحكومه بموجب النظام الحكومه لها
ان تدفع خلال 45 يوم همم من وصول اوامر
الدفع لوزاره الماليه
صارعنا في ذلك ايضا سارعنا في متابعه
الجهات الحكوميه ورفع فعاليه الادارات
الماليه في الجهات الحكوميه لتسريع عمليات
الدفع لو لاحظ سنوات سابقه كان الربع
الرابع
في مدفوعات القطاع الخاص همم انخفض الى
يمكن تقريبا
العامل الماضي السنه هذه تقريبا في حدود
30 32%
وهذا نعتقد انه انجاز مميز للجهات
الحكوميه همم وادارتها
مطالبات ال- ال- القطاع الخاص اام
اطلقت مجموعه من الاستراتيجيات لن اتحدث
عنها لان اغطيت بشكل كبير جدا لكن ساتحدث
ويمكن تكلم سمو ولي العهد اليوم عن
الاستراتيجيه الصناعيه ونعتقد استراتيجيه
الصناعيه سيكون لها دور محوري في تمكين
القطاع الخاص ورصد لها ميزانيات مميزه
صراحه
لتمكين القطاع الخاص وتحفيز القطاع الخاص
وتوفير البنيه التحتيه وايضا من الجانب
التشريعي والتنظيمي همم تم همم تعديلات
كبيره على نظام مشتريات الحكوميه لتمكين
المحتوى المحلي
الصندوق الاستثمارات العامه اعلن عن
استهداف همم محتوى محلي 60% في المشاريع
والشركات التابعه للصندوق
الصندوق لسماره العامه ايضا
عامل حراك مميز في الاقتصاد المحلي انشا
تقريبا 60 شركه نتج عن 60 شركه هذه
ضخ كبير جدا من الطلب والدوره الاقتصاديه
في القطاع الخاص
والمهم ايضا انه تمكن من انشاء وتوفيق
تقريبا 500,000 وظيفه
للمواطنين من هذه المشاريع
همم فيما يتعلق بالارقام وانكسار
بيان الميزانيه واعلان مجلس الوزراء قبل
قليل
سننتهي هذه السنه باذن الله تعالى بارادات
تريليون و234
مليار ااا نفقات تريليون و132 وبالتالي
الفاعل سيكون في حدود المليار ال 200
مليار
ريال هذا العام العام القادم نتوقع
الايرادات في حدود تريليون 130 والنفقات
في الحدود 114
والفائز في حدود 16 مليار اااه في
توقعاتنا بشكل عام اا توقعات متحفظه وفي
بيان الميزانيه نشرنا ثلاث توقعات او
سيناريوهات للايرادات ستجدنا في بيان
الميزانيه السيناري الاساسي اللي علينا
اليوم والسيناريو متحفظ ياخذ في الاعتبار
التطورات الاقتصاديه والتغيرات الممكن على
المستوى الاقتصاد العالم التي قد تؤثر على
الايرادات في المملكه
وسناريو متفائل او اكثر همم في الايرادات
ايضا يا اختي في الاعتبار احتمالات تطورات
ايجابيه في الاقتصاد العالمي قد تؤدي
زياده في الاراده
الجيد بس يعرج على المخصصات القطاعيه
البنود العامه 165 ايه قطاع الامن 105
مليار القطاع العسكري
259 مليار وهو مرتفع كما تلاحظون عن هذا
العام عن العام الماضي
في قطاع الاداره العامه 37 والموارد
الاقتصاديه 72
مليار قطاع التنميه الصحه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه تقريبا 189 مليار ريال واا ال
ال الخدمات البلديه 63
وودن نوضح ان هناك انتقال بعد انتقال
وزاره الاسكان دمج الاسكان مع البلديات
انتقلت ميزانيه الاسكان الى القطاع البلدي
قطاع التعليم 189
مليار وقطاع التجهيزات الاساسيه
والنقل
34 مليار
تفاصيل اكثر ستجدونها باذن الله تعالى في
بيان الميزانيه للنشر قبل قليل على موقع
وزاره الماليه وايضا ادعوكم الى حضور
ملتقى الميزانيه ملتقى الميزانيه سيعقد
يوم الاحد ويوم الاثنين
سيحضر فيه عدد من اصحاب السمو المعالي
سيتحدثون بالتحديد عن قطاعاتهم وما تم
انجازها خلال هذا العام وما هو المتوقع
خلال الفتره الماضيه امامنا الارقام فيما
يتعلق بسنيرهات الايرادات
اللي تاخذ في الاعتبار تطورات الاقتصاديه
العالميه واثارها ايضا على
الاقتصاد السعودي هو الاثر المحتمل على
الارادات
في ما يتعلق
بالمدى المتوسط الارقام تشاهدونا خلفي
اجباري الايرادات المتوقعه لسنه 24
تريليون و146 مقابل تريليون 205 مليار في
عام 25 النفقات 24 تريليون 125
وفي عام 25 تريليون و134 وفائد الميزانيه
21 مليار في عام 24
وواحد 70 مليار في سنه 25
ميزانيه شكرا لكم واتمنى لنا ولكم وللوطن
ولجميع المواطنين باذن الله تعالى سنه
مباركه تبشر بالخير انا متفائل جدا من
ماتم خلال عام 22 ومتفائل اكثر
بالمستقبل لدينا فرص كبيره جدا وتحدث سمو
ولي العهد عن المواطنين ودورهم الاساسي
انا شخصيا متفائل انا فخور جدا جدا
بما اشاهده من ابناء وبنات المملكه والجهد
الكبير الذي يشاهده على مستوى وزاره
الماليه على منظومه وزاره الماليه
والهيئات والمراكز
والمكاتب التابعه لوزاره الماليه لكن شهد
ايضا على مستوى
الوزارات والاجهزه الحكوميه بشكل عام شباب
وشابات يعملون على مدار الساعه لتحقيق هذا
الهدف لديهم شغف كبير جدا نشكرهم عليه لا
اتوقف عن ذلك ان اعتقد مشاهد قفزه كبيره
جدا في القطاع الخاص
مشاهد قفزه كبيره في مجالات متعدده في
المنشات في الرواد الاعمال
رقم واحد فقط يشدني لولا نشوف العام 22
في عام 22 بقدر ما كان فيه بعض الصعوبات
اللي واجهت بعض القطاعات
عدد المنشات اللي تم انشائها مقابل لانشاء
المنشات التي تم اقفائلها في سنه 22 18 تم
انشاء ثمانيه اضعاف منشات جديده من رواد
اعمال خلال سنه 22 مقابل
جدا ما سمعناه هو الاشاده بالنمو ليس فقط
في القطاع النفطي بالايضا في القطاع الخاص
وتحدث معالي الوزير عن نمو بخمسه فاصل
تسعه في المئه بالقطاع الخاص وكذلك نمو
الاستثمار من القطاع الخاص بنسبه 20%
وذكرنا مهم جدا وهو ارتفاع عدد المنشات
التي تم انشاءها من اضعاف عدد المنشات
التي اغلقت اذن في القطاع الخاص على كل ان
دعونا اعود الان الى زميلتي نادين هاني هي
متواجده في الرياض وتتابع ارقام هذه
ميزانيه بالفعل نادين امر ملف جدا ما تحدث
عنه الان
الوزير حول اا نمو القطاع الخاص وايضا حول
مستويات التضخم يا اللي بتوقع انها تتراجع
في العام المقبل
لارا نحن بمقابله خاصه مع معالي الوزير
سالناها عن هذه الامور همم هو واضح انه
السياسات بالوقت الحاضر ثابته لا تغيير
بالسياسات الدعم الموجوده رغم انه صندوق
النقد الدولي عده مرات همم يطالب الحكومه
السعوديه بتخفيف الدعم ولكن كانت اولويه
بالفتره الماضيه مع ارتفاعات مستويات
التضخم العالميه الابقاء على حساب المواطن
على دعم اسعار الوقود ويبدو انه هذه
مستمره بالفتره القادمه من الناحيه الاخرى
مستمره ايضا سياسات الضريبيه
والعمولات التي تتقاضاها الدوله ولو انه
فسر لنا ايضا معالي الوزير بمقابله خاصه
سنسمعها بعد قليل انه في همم اعاده نظر
شامله بالنسبه همم تخفيف همم اجراءات
الضريبيه وجعل اكثر ستريم لاينز ولكن ليس
هناك من تراجع همم المستويات الضريبيه
بالفتره القادمه
وعمولات الوافدين
لو بالتالي هذا يحافظ على استمراريه
العوائد غير النفطيه على كلن لارا كان
معنا موجود ايضا ضيفنا كان حاضر المؤتمر
الصحفي ينضم الي الان الدكتور محمد مكني
استاذ الماليه والاستثمار بكليه الاقتصاد
بجامعه الامام دكتور اهلا بك قبل ان اسالك
عن المؤتمر الصحفي الشاعر مع لوزير
الماليه الجدعان الى كلمه لولي العهد نشرت
قبل قليل البيان حول الميزانيه لنذكر ابرز
ما جاء فيه
الحقيقه الف مبروك
عليها يمكن كان ابرز ما ذكره اسمه السيد
ولي العهد يمكن ركز على مساله اهميه
المواطن السعودي في هذه الارقام اللي
تحققت في الميزانيه ايضا الانجازات اللي
تحققت خلال الفتره السابقه بسبب السياسات
الاقتصاديه والاصلاحات ال- همم الماليه
اللي عملت عليها الدوله خلال يعني اطلاق
الرؤيه 20 30
الاستراتيجيات اللي اطلقت وعلى راسها يمكن
استراتيجيه الوطنيه للاستثمار
والاستراتيجيه الصناعيه واستراتيجيه
التنميه السياحيه كل هذا الاسترات يمكن
همم يعني بتعزز الاهداف الاساسيه في رؤيه
المملكه 2030 وما في شك انه هذا الهداف
تتمركز حول تنويع مصادر الايرادات خلق
الوظائف جذب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه زياده
مشاركه القطاع الخاص كل هذه الحقيقه اشار
لها اسمه ولي العهد في البيان الصحفي
واللي بيؤكد من خلالها انه فعلا احنا
اليوم الميزانيه والارقام اللي احنا
حققناها يمكن حتى تفوق المتوقع يمكن
شاهدنا يمكن كان المتوقع ان نقف عند 90
مليار اليوم احنا في عام 22 اليوم احنا
بنتحدث على ما يقارب همم 102 همم مليار
همم في الميزانيه وبالتالي هذه ما في شك
كانت نتيجه عمل جهود عمل حكومي كبير همم
خلينا نقول تناسب في السياسات يعني متفقه
للعمل للوصول لها وكانت النتائج اللي
شاهدناها خلال اليوم يمكن الكلمه كانت في
يعني في في المجمل بتتحدث على العمل
الكبير اللي قامت في السعوديه خلال الفتره
الحاليه ايضا الاشادات اللي حصلت عليها
صندوق النقد الدولي الدوله الوحيده اللي
اشاد اا يعني وغير بشكل ايجابي نمو الناتج
المحلي خلال عام واحد السعوديه كان بيتوقع
في 7.6% بعد كده احنا قال حتتجاوز ثمان
6% وبالتالي هذا دليل واضح انه حتى
الاشادات الدوليه بالنسبه للاقتصاد
السعودي يعني بتؤكد العمل الكبير
بالكلام الذي سمعناه الان من وزير الماليه
قبل ان اسالك عن ارقام الميزانيه انا تجد
انه اول شيء تفاعل انا وجد التفاؤل كبير
جدا حقيقه يمكن عن الوزير في اكثر من مره
بيقول انا متفائل بال- بال- بالعام 23 همم
مثل ما كنا احنا متفاعلين يمكن بعد بالضبط
الكوارتر الثاني في عام 22 اصبح التفاؤل
كبير لهذا العام حتى نصل لاخره ايضا ربما
نصل لناتج محلي اكبر من المتوقع كانت
وزاره الماليه تتوقع انه ربما نكون عند
سبع فاصله سته بالمئه لانه احنا نتحدث على
8.5% همم ايضا قد ندخل الى نادي التريليون
لاول مره في همم القيمه الاسميه للنتيجه
التريليون دولار في في همم في الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي همم حتى نهايه هذا العام
اضف الى ذلك ايضا النظره المستقبليه يعني
من خلال السيناريوهات اللي وضعتها همم
يعني الماليه السعوديه سواءا همم النظره
الاساسيه او السيناري والاساسي والسيناريو
المتحف والسينار المتفاعل قد نصل لمستويات
اعلى ايضا اخذنا الى نقطه ضيفينا
بالستوديو توقعوا انه الميزانيه موضوع على
اسعار ما بين 78 ل 80 دولار هذا همم بيس
لاين سيناريو يعني في بعد متفائل اكثر منه
ما رايك بهذه الارقام ليست متفائله بعض
الشيء لل 2023 خلينا نرجع للعام 22 احنا
كنا في البدايات كانت همم السعوديه ايضا
وضعت ارقام وذكر انها هي متفائله
يتجاوزناها في هذا العام يعني المتوقع
احنا تجاوزنا فانا اعتقد السيناري الموضوع
اللي همم للعام 23 صحيح ان هو بننظر لانه
نظرا متفائله كبيره لكن انا اعتقد ان
الظروف المحيطه عندنا اليوم ويخصوصا للدول
المنتجه للنفط همم لازالت الامور انا اقول
انها تصب في مصلحه الدول وبالتالي زياده
ارادات همم زياد ايضا نحن كمان هذا
الاسبوع عندنا زياده في عمليات الانفاق من
اجل انه يسرع في عمليه انهاء المشاريع
الاساسيه اللي هي تكون رافد اساسي يعني في
الغد بالنسبه للميزانيه السعوديه والنتائج
يعني اعتقد في اللي قاعدين نش 22 تعطينا
تفائل كبير لعم 23 معتقد انه ربما تكون
يعني خلينا نقول بعيدين على انه احنا نوصل
لها واكبر دليل مساله التضخم التضخم
العالم اليوم في المتوسط على المستوى
العالم يتوقع ان يكون هناك ثمانيه فاصله
همم يعني فوق الثمانيه بالمئه بينما في
السعوديه احنا يعني اليوم بشهاده ايضا همم
يعني المنظمات دوليه انه احنا نحتوي
التضخم اقل من ثلاثه% ومتوقع انه في العام
القادم نصل الى مستوى اقل من ذلك الى
حوالي 2.1% وبالتالي فعليا انا اقول انه
هذه السيناريات خصوصا السيناري المتفائل
قد له حقيقه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور شكرا
لارى يبقى بالطبع موضوع توزيع همم يعني
هذا الموضوع اللي بعد حتى الان ليس لدينا
اجابات واضحه حوله ال 102 مليار المحققه
بال220 كيف سيتم توزيعها علما بان صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه عليه المتطلبات عاليه
للانفاق محليا بالاضافه الى الاستثمارات
الخارجيه لتنويع همم المملكه خارج
النفط والى قطاعات همم تلميع جغرافي
وتنويع على القطاعات ايضا بالاضافه الى كل
الانفاق الداخلي على الجيجا الجيجا بروجكت
هذه الاسئله بالطبع سوف نوجهها لضيوفنا
نادين شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه على كل هذه
التغطيه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا دعونا نذكر بارقام الميزانيه
التي صدرت اليوم في السعوديه وارقام افضل
من المتوقع
لارقام اذن للفوائد الفوائد العامه الماضي
العام الجاري عفوا وكذلك فوائد مستمره في
الاعوام المقبله اذا نذكر بارقام
الميزانيه الارادات اتحدث هنا عن 2023 الى
ذات عند التريليون و130 مليار ريال فيما
بلغت النفقات التريليون و14 مليار ريال
وفائد متوقع بقيمه 16 مليار هذا الفائض
يشكل 0.4% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
للمملكه ولكن ماذا عن الارقام الفعليه
المحققه للعام الجاري 2022 الاردادات
الفعليه وصلت الى تريليون و 200 و34 مليار
ريال مقارنه مع المقدره عند وضع الميزانيه
بقيمه مليون و45 مليار ريال ان فقط ايضا
جاءت اعلى من التقديرات الاوليه عند
التريليون
و132 مليار ريال مقارنه مع تقديرات
الاوليه بانفاق عند 955 مليار ريال ولكن
الفائض ارتفع الى 102 مليار ريال وهو اول
فائض تحققه ميزانيه المملكه منذ عام 2013
لنتوقف قليلا مع تطور العجز والفائض من
اعوام 2016 حتى
2025 كما قلنا اخر فائض حققتهم ميزانيه
المملكه كان عند عام 2013 عند 180 مليار
ريال منذ 2014 بدانا بتشجير العدس وبلغ
اعلى مستوياتها عام 2015 عندها 367 مليار
وفي عام 2016 كان العجز عند 300 مليار
ريال تناقص العش تدريجيا حتى
19 ولكن سنه الجائحه عام 2020 سجل العجز
قفزه قبل ان يعود للتراجع في 2021 العام
الحالي عدنان الفوائد بقوه حيث وصل الفائض
كما تحدثنا الى 102 مليار ريال ما يشكل
2.6% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي توقعات
للمدى المتوسط هو باستمرار تسجيل هذه
الفوائد التي ستصل بحسب التقديرات الان
الموضوع الى 71 مليار ريال عام
بالتاكيد فوائد عام 2022 تاثرت بشكل واضح
بالارتفاع القوي الذي شهدناه في اسعار
النفط لاحظوا انه بدانا العام الماضي عام
2021 عند متوسط سعر لخامه برنت بحدود ال
55 دولار البرميل بعد عام صعب للغايه
لاسواق الطاقه في 20 20 مع انتشار رائحتك
ارتفعت الاسعار بشكل تدريجي منذ مطلع فينه
21 حتى سجلنا قمه لمتوسط سعر براند عند
117 ونصف دولار للبرميل في يونيو هذا
العام طبعا في ظل تطورات الحرف في
اوكرانيا ثم بدات الاسعار بتراجع ولكنها
كانت عند معادلات 90 دولار خلال سبتمبر
واكتمبر ونوفمبر هنا بالطبع اتحدث عن
متوسط سعر برينت الشهري ولا ننسى انه
اسعار برنت في التداولات اليوميه وصلت
العام الحالي الى اعلى من ذلك الى 100 وب
139 دولار للبرميل
سياسه الدين العام من ناحيه اخرى تماشت
خلال السنوات مع التطورات في تحضير
الميزانيه العامه نلاحظ منذ عام 2015 كان
الدين العام عند حوالي 142 مليار ريال ما
شكل حينها حوالي 6% من الاقتصاد ازدادت
المديونيه ضمن خطه لوزاره الماليه لضمان
بناء علاقه مع اسواق الدين تسمح للمملكه
بالاستدانه في اوقات الحاجه وايضا في
اوقات الرخاء محفظه الدين العام تصل اليوم
الى
985 مليار لتقارب 25% من الناتج المحل
الاجمالي علما بان مكتب اداره الدين قام
في 2022 بالسداد مبكر لقروض دوليه تستحق
في السنوات القليله المقبله لاداره
المحفظه بشكل افضل ومن المتوقع ان يتراجع
الدين العام الى 900 وواحد وخمسين مليار
ريال ما يعني ثلاثه ونصف 100 من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي في العام
ولكن كيف تمت اداره محفظه زين العام
السعودي في السنوات القليله الماضيه بين
الاقراض والسداد من الواضح انه عام 2020
كان عام كورونا شهد حجم الاقراض بطبيعه
الحال الاكبر عند 220 مليار ريال بينما
شهد العام الذي يليه عام 2021
اكبر حجم سداد بلغ 73 مليار ريال مع العلم
ان الاقراض كان دائما اكثر من ضعف حجم
السداد الا في العام الحالي 2022 تلاحظ
تقليص الفجوه بين السداد والاقراض
اما في ما يتعلق بالنمو الاقتصادي
للسعوديه في العام الجاري كان الاسرى بين
دول مجموعه العشرين جاء عنده 8.5% تقارن
هذه الارقام بوثيره اضعف للنمو في السنوات
السابقه بالطبع وتقارن حتى بنكيماج
اقتصادي بحدود 2% في عام الجائحه عام 2020
عندما اوقف فايروس كورونا الاقتصاد حول
العالم مع العلم ان نمو الاقتصاد غير
النفطي تسارع هذا العام ليلامس سته بالمئه
وايضا ليسهم بقوه في اجمالي النمو ولكن
النمو في العام المقبل من المتوقع ان يسجل
مستويات اقل عندها ثلاثه فاصل واحد بالمئه
مدعوم بالانشطه النفسيه وغير النفطيه ايضا
وليرتفع الى خمسه فاصل سبعه في المئه في
العام 2020
و4.5% في العام
2025 وهنا تحدث عن ارتفاع حجم الاقتصاد
السعودي ما فوق التريليون دولار
لنقارن هذه الارقام اذا الارقام النمو
للسعوديه بمجموعه من دول مجموعه ال 20
بحسب اخر التقديرات الصادره من صندوق
النقد الدولي والتي صدرت في اكتوبر الماضي
الصين
3.2% مستويات نمو
اليابان 1.7
الهند
6.8%
السعوديه بحسب تقديرات الصندوق النقد
الدولي عند 7.6 اقل من تقديرات السعوديه
نفسها روسيا كماش ب 3.4% المانيا نمو بسيط
ب 1.5% فرنسا 2.5% وبريطانيا ثلاثه فاصل
سته بالمئه الاقتصاد البريطاني هذا العام
من همم من المتوقع ان يدخل في الركود
وايضا في احتماليه ركود للاغتصاب الامريكي
الذي همم نام بحسب تقديرات الصندوق فاصل
سته في المئه في العام 2022 ولكن ما هي
توقعات الصندوق لنمو الاقتصادي لهذه الدول
في العام المقبل تختلف الصوره كليه ولكن
التوقعات تبقى ايجابيه لاقتصاد المملكه
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
تضخم مشاهدينا في العام 2022 كان تحدي
الاصعب للاقتصاد العالمي والذي سبب تحول
البنوك المركزيه للسياسه النقديه المتشدده
والتي راينا فيها ارتفاعات متتاليه وقويه
للفوائد للفوائد وهي بدورها ايضا ما يساهم
في افاق ركود الاقتصاد العالمي السعوديه
اتخذت اجراءات لحمايه الاقتصاد من التضخم
نتحدث بالطبع عن تثبيت اسعار الطاقه
والنتيجه كانت معدل تضخم من الادنى عالميا
عند 2.6
مع توقعات حتى بتراجع مستويات التضخم الى
اثنين فاصل واحد في المئه في العام المقبل
كيف تقارن هذه الارقام ببقيه العالم نعود
لتقديرات صندوق النقد الدولي للتضخم سين
مستويات تضخم قريبه عند اثنين فاصل اثنين
بالمائه اليابان اي متدنيه عند اثنين
بالمئه الهند عند 6.9% مستوي التضخم
مرتفعه روسيا
13.8 بالمئه اكيد بسبب الحرب والعقوبات
المانيا مستويات تضخم مرتفعه 8.5% اقل
فرنسا
ب5.8 بريطانيا فوق التسعه بالمائه
والولايات المتحده فوق الثمانيه في المئه
وقبل ان اعود الى ضيوفي
نتوقف مع توزيع ونتذكر كيف تتوزع ارقام
الميزانيه العام المقبل على القطاعات
المختلفه الصحه والتنميه الاجتماعيه مئه و
189 مليار ريال الخدمات البلديه 63 مليار
التعليم
189 مليار ريال ودائما التعليم يكون له
همم من اكثر القطاعات يعني همم نسبتها
بالنفقات القطاع العسكري بالطبعه في زياده
فيه بالمقارنه مع ميزانيه العمل الماضي
259 مليار وتجهيزات الاساسيه والنقل كان
فيها تراجعات الاكبر من ناحيه النفقات
المخصصه لهذا القطاع همم في هذا العام
المقارنه مع العام الماضي ووصلت الى 34
مليار ريال
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اعود الى ضيوفي وارحب بها من
جديد
رئيس قسم الابحاث في شركه الراجحي كافه
الدكتور نايف كبير الاقتصاديه في بنك
الرياض الان اسماعيل العاني رئيس القطاع
الحكومي في كي في ام جي اهلا وسهلا بكم
سيد اسماعيل دعني ابدا معك
وتحدثنا مع مازن ودكتور نايف عن الايرادات
وتوقعاتهم للاردادات ولكن لم نتطرق بعض
للنفقات وبالتالي اود الوقوف عند ارقام
النفقات مصاريف 2022 بدايه كانت اعلى من
المقدر ب 14% هل تعتبر انه هذه النسبه
مقبوله ولماذا هل بسبب ارتفاع الاردادات
لذلك ارتفعت المصاريف همم وايضا من ناحيه
اخرى ان نفقات الراسماليه في العام الماضي
في العام جاري عفوا 2022 نامت ب 29 بالمئه
ما الاسباب برايك وراء ذلك وهل تكفي انه
نفقات الراسماليه هي فقط 14% من الميزانيه
هل هي كافيه برايك
مساكم الله بالخير جميعا اولا وامسي عليك
وعلى زملائي ايضا في همم اللي استضفتيهم
قبلي
بالنسبه للنفقات طبعا انتم شايفين اكثر من
سؤال
خليني ابدا فيهم بس همم
بشكل سريع همم اولا بالنسبه لفتاه اعتقد
انه زياده
18.8 تقريبا من اللي كان مقدر في
الميزانيه عند وضعها في نهايه العام
السابق اعتقد انه همم انه انه مقبول
مبدئيا همم والسبب في ذلك انه زي ما ذكر
يمكن ايضا انه وزير الماليه انه همم
الحكومه قامت بتعزيز الدعم تحت بنود
الضمان حساب المواطن المما ادى الى
السيطره على معدلات التضخم نوعا ما هذا من
ناحيه اخرى تعجيل في تنفيذ بعض المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه وايضا نرى انه بزياده همم
يعني همم اقل همم اقل من من ما من ما كان
في جانب الايرادات النفطيه بشكل رئيسي حسب
التغييرات الاوليه هذا من ناحيه ارقام
النفقات
بسم الله
الراس
في العام 2022 ب29
برايك ما هي الاسباب الرئيسيه وراء ذلك
وحاليا بالميزانيه الجديده بتشكل تقريبا
14% من مجربه لان فقد سؤال هل هي كافيه مش
ضروري يكون عندنا نفقات راسماليه اكبر مع
وجود الصناديق الكبرى مثل همم والصندوق
التنميه
نعم اعتقد صغير هذا سبب رئيسي وجود
الصناديق الوطنيه الان باضافه في اي اف
يتعزز دور صندوق التنميه الوطني وايضا
يعني صندوق اللي يشمل جميع الصناديق
التنميه الوطنيه من صندوق التنميه الصناعي
صندوق التنميه العقاري الزراعي صندوق
البنيه التحتيه صندوق التنميه السياحي الى
اخره فهذه الصناديق طبعا احنا ما نرى
مصروفاتها من ضمن النفقات الراسماليه في
الميزانيه وان كان جزء من الفوائظ حسب
الاعلان سيسخر لدعم همم موجه لهذه
الصناديق الوطنيه وبالتالي اعتقد انه
ال14% هي هي يعني ليست همم ليست قراءه
شامله لجميع في المصاريف همم الراسماليه
بالاضافه لانه ايضا في دور الانقطاع الخاص
يفطر انه يكون معزز من خلال برنامج الشريك
همم والبرامج ال- ال- الاخرى اللي تم
الاعلان عنها همم في العام السابق من همم
من عند اطلاق برنامج الشريك وايضا التزام
البي اي اف همم في بعض المشاريع داخل
المملكه
موضوع اساسي عن بنتابعوا ذكرناه هو همم
يعني كما تحدثنا موضوع التوزيع الفوائد
المحققه من هذه الميزانيه ولم يتخذ بعض
القرار كيف سوف توزع هذه الفوائد بين نقل
للاحتياطات احتياطات الحكومه لدى سامه
وتوزيعها على همم على الصناديق ام
استخدامها لسداد جزء من الدين ويبدو
بالمقابله التي سوف تبث بعد قليل مع زميله
نادين هاني لاجرتها مع وزير الماليه لا
استعمال للفوائد لتخفيض الدين ولكن سؤال
هنا الفوائد المتوقعه مازن في العام
المقبل 16 مليار ريال
بنفس الوقت عم بقول شفنا انه الاحتياطات
لدى احتياطات الحكوميه لدى سامه سترتفع
فقط في خمسه مليارات ريال
كيف فينا نفسر ذلك علما انه ايضا
باللقاء مع وزير الماليه قال انه من
الارجح في العام المقبل معظم الفوائد تذهب
للاحتياطات ليش ما عم تعكس كل هذه
الاحتياطات برايك ما بعرف اذا عندك تفسير
جواب السؤال الاساسي
سؤالك مركب ما اقدر اقول لك وين بتروحي
فلوس اذا قبل ما تفكر انا اول شيء المعيار
الاول اعتقد هو الانفاق والانفاق مرتبط
بحدين الدين لا يتجاوز 50% من الناتج
المحلي هو الان زي ما شفتي 24.9 وفي حد
ادنى للاحتياطيات كويس اللي ممكن تسحب
منها الاحتياط متوقع ترتفع 394 اوكي نهايه
92 نهايه هذه السنه لكن ايضا عندك حد ادنى
فيها لازم ما تخرج عنه حركه انت سالتي انه
ارتفاع الانفاق على المقدر ارتفع 18% طول
ما انت مرتبط بحجم معين بين هالحدين
الاحتياطيات والديون هذا يجي يعطي مرونه
الميزانيه في الحرم اوكي
وايضا بناء احتياطيات ماليه لمواجهه اي
ازمات خارجيه صدمات خارجيه ممكن دوله
تستخدم فيها الان مشكله الاحتياطيه في
مشكله ارتفاع اسعار الفائده السايبر
واصلاح اليوم
5.3.4
طيب شفنا اسامه
حدود 17 مليار في البنوك
لو اخرنا اصلا من كافه الرقم اكبر من ذلك
فبالتالي تستخدم هذه الاموال بالنسبه
لسامح للحفاظ على النظام النقدي طبعا
موجود في المملكه في مصلحه المملكه لكن
بالنسبه لها وزاره الماليه المعيار
اي ممكن تسير في حركه
السؤال اللي بعدك تساليني اياه ليش ما
انعكس على سامع انت تشوفين سمكه فيلاك
يعني انت تعرفين هذا الشيء في تاخير
الاموال ما توصل من ارامكو انه انها تدخل
في الان هذا النشره الان ظهرت لك في
ديسمبر تشكل الاموال يحتاج انك تشوفين شهر
اخر متاخر ويكون عاد في بينهم يعني همم
حركه الاموال خلال الفتره دي يكون في فارق
بسيط بينهم
يعني الميزانيه وصلت احتياطات للقطاع
العام لدى سامه الى 399 هذا من المتوقع
بنهايه العامه المقبل ما يشير انه حجمها
الاحتياطات راح يرتفع فقط بخمسه مليار
ريال في العام المقبل هذا ما قصدته همم
مازن بنفس الوقت
ما هو ما هو ممكن يسحب منها تحال الى جهه
اخرى لكن ارجع اقول لك انه هل تذهب
الاموال للصناديق الاخرى هل تبقى في اسامه
هذا يظن ضمن اسئله مركبه من ناحيه الصدمات
الخارجيه من ناحيه احتياج الانفاق حركه
اسعار البترول خلال السنه لا يوجد قانون
هو سؤال مركب يعتمد على عده مدخلات طب
خلينا نسال الدكتور نايف رايه بهذا
الموضوع وبرايك ما يعني
الاحتياطات اذا تم وضعه عند سامه
بالمقارنه اذا تم توزيعها على الصناديق من
ناحيه المالتي بلاير افكت على الاقتصاد
السعودي اي سيناري هو الافضل برايك
شكرا جزيلا بالنسبه للفوائد وين تضع هل هي
في البنك المركزي او تسريح
[موسيقى]
الاول وضعت الموضع في البنك المركزي البنك
المركزي زي ما تفضل مازن ممكن يستخدم في
الاوبن ماركه بريس
الاقتصاد
المحلييه او استثمارات خارجيه في حاله
خارجين عوائد عليها راح تاخذ وقت بنقفله
بالنسبه ل- اا تم تسريع بروجيكت واحد راح
يشوفها بسرعه النتائجها سريعه
والناحيه اللي عندهم ناحيه الكودي الان زي
الان في عندنا في حال كان الاقتصاد همم
في الاقتصاد حاليا تستمر
في حاله لان اقتصاد الان وما انت عالي
وهذا اللي نشوفه الحين ممكن اكس هو عندنا
الاشياء الممكن المطروحه عند تسديد الديون
جزء من الديون عندنا الاغلب من الديون
اللي عندنا همم سكس بيت وعندنا سعودي ففي
حال عندنا الفلوس
فائده في التسديد جزء من البروتين همم
وهو
الفلوتين يعني النسبه بشكل يعني حوالي 15%
او حتى اقل من نسبه الدين الفائده متغيره
معظم الدين يبقى
بفائده ثابته
سيد اسماعيل بما انه عم نفتح موضوع الدين
دعنا نتوقف عنده بدي رايك بالسياسه
المديونيه اللي تبع اداره الدين بوزاره
الماليه اولا اللجوء الى السوق المحلي
وليس الاسواق العالميه مره واحده تم فقط
اصدار سندات دوليه هذا العام وكان في شهر
اكتوبر على ما اظن بين سندات والسقوط كانت
بحدود الخمسه مليار دولار هل هذا
السيناريو هو الامثل برايك لماذا فضلته
الحكومه السعوديه همم لم تؤثر الم تمتص
السيوله همم وهذا ظاهر بارتفاعات معدات
همم معدلات السايبر الى مستويات قياسيه
نعم شكرا لك طبعا
اعتقد انه مركز مركز
اداره الدين اداره باحترافيه عاليه
ومعايير وسقوف
مسبقها مثل الاتفاق
اعتقد اولا اختيار الوصول الى السوق
الاسواق المحليه او الاسواق العامه
العالميه هو يعني يدخل فيه اكثر من عامل
همم احد العوامل يمكن اللي اللي اللي ممكن
تخلي وزاره الماليه تتجه الى الاسواق
العالميه وعدم يعني مراعاه عمق السوق وعدم
مزاحمه القطاع الخاص في همم
الاستفاده من همم من الاقراض المحلي بما
انه تم يعني لم يتم توجه الاسواق العالميه
بنفس المستوى اعتقد ان احنا مازلنا ضمن او
تحت همم السقف او المعيار اللي يسبب
اشكاليه اعتقد انه انه هناك اشكاليه
حقيقيه في همم
في السيوله واعتقد انه ايضا همم السياسه
في مساله تمويل او يعني الدين العام ايضا
تستخدم الفرص همم واعتقد ذاكره الحكومه
اكثر في اكثر من همم من مكان هذا الامر
بشكل عام سواء في الاسواق المحليه او
الاسواق العالميه اعتقد انه الاداء جيد
احنا مازلنا يعني ما زلنا السنه هذه السنه
القادمه حسب البيان راح يكون دون ال 25%
وهذا تحسن بسبب ارتفاع الناتج المحلي بشكل
رئيسي ولكن نبقى دون بالتاكيد معدلات
الدول النظيره في مجموعه ال 20 همم ايضا
همم يتوجه هذا الرقم لانه الانخفاض مع
المحافظه على مستودين بسبب ان شاء الله
النمو المتوقع انه هذا هذا هو الاهم اذا
كان في فعلا اشكاليه في ضغط على الاسواق
المحليه سنرى ان الحكومه ستوجه
للاسواق العالميه كما ذكرت كما حصل في
السنه هذه
دكتور نايف بدي رايك بهذا الموضوع برايك
ما هي السياسه الامثل للحكومه من ناحيه
الاستدانه في المرحله المقبله هل يجب
التركيز الان على الاسواق العالميه لاصدار
الديون نظرا للاصدارات الكثيفه التي تمت
محليا
في نظري همم
الاسواق العالميه هذه ما يحط الضغط على
المحليه ولكن او راح يعزز مستويات
في البنك المركزيه في حال تم الاستدامه من
السوق المحلي بانه راح يعز السوق همم
بشكل عام السيوله من صعب انها فقط
للسعوديه حجم كبير جدا والان لا يعتمد بس
فقط على الميزانيه وزاره الماليه وزاره
الماليه الان تجاوزون ولا المتوقع في
الاقتصاد السعودي من الان حتى 2030
بحوالي 27
متوقع بشكل كبير الضغط راح يكون من جهات
اخرى سواء كان الاستدانه من سوق المحلي او
استدلال السوق الخارجي لا اعتقد فيه اي
طيران لكن استراتيجيه تومكسمايزر
النمو الكبير بالقروض حتى من القطاع الخاص
في ظل ارتفاع قوي باسعار الفائده هل
تتوقعوا استمرار ذلك ام لا سوف يتباطئ
الطلب
بشكل مختصر شديد لو سمحت
متناسب مع زياده في النمو
طيب السعوديه الان عندنا اقتصاد السعوديه
راح يكون النمو
ولكن بشكل اقل من الصراحه
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور نايف الغيث كبير
الاقتصاديا في بنك الرياض واشكر ضيوف
اسماعيل العاني رئيس القطاع الحكومي في
كيف انجي وايضا المشاركات مازن رئيس قسم
الابحاث في شركه الراجحي كافه شكرا جزيلا
لكم
[موسيقى]
وفي لقاء خاص مع العربيه اشار محمد
الجدعان وزير الماليه السعودي الى ان
اعاده هيكله الماليه العامه تضمنت زياده
مشاركه الايرادات غير النفطيه في مجمل
الارادات كما اشار جدعان الى ان الجزء
الاكبر من الفائض في الميزانيه يذهب الى
زياده الاحتياطات مؤكدا عدم تخصص تخصيص اي
جزء منه لسداد الدين
الايرادات طبعا دائما الحكومه في تقديرها
الايرادات تكون متحفضه لانه ناخذ في
الاعتبار المخاطر في الاقتصاد العالمي
اللي ممكن تطرا في اي وقت ولذلك كانت
التحفظات السابقه ايضا او التقديرات
السابقه كانت متحفظه الزياده الاساسيه اجت
من الجزئين الايرادات غير النفطيه
تحققت
النسبه اعلى من مكان متوقع لان النشاط
الاقتصادي كان اعلى الان اصبحت في
الرياضيات
نسبه تقريبا 16.8
من الناتج المحلي غير النفطي
16.8 فكل ما زاد ال- همم النشاط الاقتصادي
كلما زادت الارادات
هذا جزء وبالتالي لانه النشاط ااا
الاقتصادي للقطع الخاص لسنه 22 تقريبا
سنصل الى 5.9 هذا ادى الى زياده الايرادات
غير النفطيه جزء طبعا من الايرادات
النفطيه لانه كان ايضا نتحفظ في تقديراتها
الان وصلتنا ارقام المحدثه من وزاره
الطاقه وبالتالي صار في فرق 12 مليار
اضافيه في الفوائد انما اذا نظرنا الى
الارادات 2022 المحقق تريليون و234 العام
القادم تريليون 130 مليار فهي ليست اقل
بكثير علما انه 22 كان فيها سعر نفط قياس
المتوسط كان عالي وصلنا ببران 328 باعلى
سعر والانتاج الانتاج السعوديه كان قبل
الاعلان عن التخفيضات الاخيره تخفيضات
الانتاج دخلت حيث التنفيذ نوفمبر فبالتالي
ستؤثر على العام القادم لم تؤثر على 2022
من هنا السؤال هل انتم
متحفظين ام لا بس نفط المجدول لل 2003 23
الارادات عاليه بالفعل المجرد اولا النهج
اللي اتبعته المملكه خلال ال 45 يعني مهم
جدا نستحضر الخلفيه اخر خمس سنوات صار في
اعاده هيكله كبيره جدا
للمريه العامه ومن ضمن هذا زياده
همم المشاركه الايرادات غير النفطيه في
مجبل الاراده كانت اقل من تقريبا 9% في
2015 اهلا وصلنا الى 16.8 تقريبا 17% هذا
بالتالي يخفف من اثر تقلبات اسعار الطاقه
تقريبا 60% من الايرادات لكنها اقل من
السابق كانت بشكل 90% هذا السبب السبب
الثاني نشوف في بيان الميزانيه اللي نشر
قليل وضعنا ثلاثه سيناريوس
للايرادات سيناريو الاساسي اللي معلن
للسنه القادمه وفي سيناريو متحفظ اكثر في
الاعتبار التطورات الاقتصاد العالمي
والضغوط سواء من ناحيه
اسعار الفائده وخلافه وفي سيناري اخر همم
اكثر تفاعلا ياخذ في الاعتبار ما قد ينتج
من ركود اقل من المتوقع وحتى انفتاح بعض
الاسواق ما في ذلك اسواق الصين واقتصاد
الصين ابكر من المتوقع كده الحالتين
الماليه العامه تاخدها في الاعتبار عندنا
التعامل مع الارادات الاقل وسنرها التعامل
مع الاردادات الاعلى بس نحن عم نحكي عن
البيسكيز سناريو بس قبل ان اقدم هذه
الجزئيه بال22 كم كان متوسط
الاسعار 101 تقريبا
بنهايه ربع الثالث 149 مليار ونصف انا هنا
العام على قائد 102 مليار بالتالي في
انفاق ارتفع بالربع الرابع ما هو
ليس بالضروره شيء لانه
انفاق ترتفع
الانفاق ارتفع ولا حتى يمكن الارادات
مستوى الارادات انخفاضات لانوس اسعار
النفط
انخفضت لكن بشكل عام الانفاق السنوي على
مدى الاربع خمس سنوات اللي راحت بدا
يتوازن اول كنا نشوف انفاق قليل جدا في
الاربع في ثلاثه ارباع الاولى ومن ثم نشوف
زياده كبيره جدا في الربع الاخير بدا هذا
يتقلص لانه صار في اداره اكثر للتدفقات
النقديه اداره تحسنت عند الجهات الحكوميه
برفع المطالبات
اتمثل العمليه هذه مثلا اعتماد القطاع
الخاص بدا يستطيع الان رفع المطالبات في
وزاره الماليه وبالتالي التابع مع الجهاز
الدفع صار الدفع احسن بس بشكل عام الربع
دائما يكون في انفاق اكثر لان في تسويات
في همم معالجات محاسبيه حتى ما بعض الجهات
الاخرى اللي يرتفع فيها الان فقط معالي
الو في اخر لقاء لنا سالتك عن توزيع
الفوائد ذكرت لاربع ابواب همم لدعم
الاحتياطي العام للدوله البيئه اي عفوا
عندي اف المشاريع الاساسيه واطفاء دين فيك
تعطينا توزيع هذا الفائض كيف سيتم بان هذه
الابواب وهل غلطت باي من الابواب ام لا هي
اربعه يعني اعتقد هي اربعه
يعني نستمر فيها هي التوزيع ياتي بعد
انتهاء بعد اقفال السنه الماليه النظاما
بموجب النظام المحاسبي للقطاع العام ما
الان ما نقدر نقول مثلا يتحقق فعليا لما
تقفل الحسابات في نهايه السنه
الجزء الاغلب بروح لزياده الاحتياط لكن لم
يتكرر ذلك القرار في النهايه اللجنه
الماليه تقرر كم سيذهب الى الاحتياطات كم
سيذهب الى صندوق التنميه كم سيذهب الى
السوق الامارات العامه كم سيذهب الى سداد
لانه حاليا لا نعتقد انه بيذهب همم شيء من
الاحتياطات لسداد الدين فقلصت لك اياها من
اربعه الى ثلاثه خلينا بس اسالك ما تم
الاتفاق يعني كمان صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه بده يوضع ميزانيه وبالتالي ما في
ارادي اتفاق على كم سيذهب الى تدعيم صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه صندوق الاستماره
العامه لا يوجد لدي اطلاقا تحدي في
السيوله فاذا كانت يذهب له شيء من من
الفوائد سيكون زياده راس مال لا يحتاجها
لسنه 23 عشان بس نكون واضحين سنه صندوق
السماوات العامه
عنده مجلس اداره المستقل همم
يقرها عندما يكفي من السيوله والاصول
للتعامل مع حاجاتهم للانفاق في سنه 23
نحنا نتكلم على مبدا
هل نحتاج الى وجود هذه
الفوائد في الاحتياطي ام نصل الى مرحله ان
اعتقد من الافضل ان يتم استغلالها
وتوجيهها لصندوق الاستماره العامه او
صندوق التنميه الوطنيه لاستغلالها اكثر في
تنميه الاقتصاد المحليه فاذن الان تذهب
الى الاحتياطي ومن بعده بيصير في قرار من
الاحتياطي
معالي الوزير الاحتياطي النقد الاجنبي لدى
اسامه ملفت انه من سنه لم يرتفع لماذا
تقريبا
الفرق بشكل عام انه عندنا يعني نفقات راس
ماليه هائله ليس فقط في الحكومه في
الحكومه في القطاع الخاص في صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه اللي في البداياتها قد
تتطلب واردات اكثر احنا مازلنا في مرحله
توطين استبدال الوالدات في المنتجات
المحليه هذا الاستراتيجيه تاخذ الوقت الى
ان تكتمل في بدايتها سيكون هناك فعلا
واردات اكبر وبالتالي تستهلك جزء من
الاحتياطي الاجنبي لكن اعتقد انه كان في
زياده خلال السنه بالنسبه للمشاريع
الاساسيه والاستراتيجيه هذا الباب الثالث
خلينا نقول لاستخدام الاحتياطي ماذا
تقصدون بها واي يعني اعطينا فكره اوضحه عن
هذا الباب اعطيكي امثله همم في خلال
الجائحه في 20 سنه 20 20 21 همم بعد
استراتيجيات تم تاجيل تنفيذ هذا لانه ما
كان بالامكان تنفيذ السياحه على سبيل
المثال ما كان بالامكان التنفيذ جزء من
استراتيجياتهم عندك كلام فرصه طالما عندك
القدره الماليه
وعندك القدره على التنفيذ
وعندك الانتاجيه همم الاقتصاد ما زال في
فجوه الاقتصاد قادر على النمو
بمراحل كبيره الى الان تستطيع ان تعجب
تقول اللي فاتكم في سنه 20 21 عطني خطه في
سنه 23 ولا حتى في 22 سويناها جزئيا 23
انك تعجل ببعض المبادرات حقتك اعلنا عن
مبادره مثلا استراتيجيه الصناعه الوطنيه
24 و25
اذا كان عندنا القدره على التموين نقول
لهم وش المبادرات الاكثر اثرا لتمكين
القطاع الخاص
وتنميه الاقتصاد اللي ممكن ناجر فيها
وهكذا على مجموعه اخرى
همم
بدي استوضح منك نقطه نحن دائما نقول
الجيجا بروجيكس والمشاريع الضخمه مموله من
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه ولكن اليس هناك
جزئيه من الحكومه من الميزانيه مثل البنا
تحتيه لها وغيره مثلا
فيه امم عندنا مخصص في الميزانيه اوكي
للمشاريع الكبرى سنويا
لماذا يخصص لانه فيه ال مشاريع ليست
بالظروف فقط الصندوق المشاريع حتى القطاع
الخاص الاخرى المشاريع النوعيه تحتاج الى
بنيه تحتيه تحميلها للقطاع الخاص او
للصندوق ليس من الهاتف لانه يفترض ان
الحكومه توفر
البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه لتوصيل
الخدمات الى هذه المشاريع هذه لنا لها
ميزانيه من ضمن ميزانيه الحكومه سنويا ال-
الميزان اللي مخصصه اعتقد العام الماضي
كانت في حدود 30 او اكثر من 30 مليون
فقط
وال23 كمان اعتقد رقم مشابه تقريبا ونفس
الشيء يمكن فيه 24 فيها يعني مشاريع بني
تحتيه للمشاريع الكبرى ستستمر لانه تنفيذ
حتى المشاريع الكبرى هو على مدى سنوات الى
20 30 همم الوزير لانه الوقت ضيق اسالك
بعض الاسئله السريعه بالنسبه لموضوع
الضرائب اليوم السعوديه بدها تكون منافسه
لجذب القطاع الخاص ولكن موضوع الفرق
الضريبي مثلا
مثلا عمولات الوافده تجعل التؤثر سلبا على
التنفسيه المملكه وبالتالي هل في اي نيه
لتغيير هذين الامرين الفات ومعموله
الوافدين اولا في في
اقتصاد زيد اقتصاد المملكه امن المهم جدا
ان تنظر الى مجموعه من العلويات
والاصلاح الهيكل احيانا يتطلب النظره
الشامل
المهم هو كم اجمالي العب الاقتصادي على
القطاع الخاص من الرسوم ولا من الضرائب
في الدراسات صندوق النقد الدولي حتى
المؤسسات دوليه الاخرى بما في ذلك ال ال
او اي سي سي دي او منظمه التجاره والتعاون
الاقتصادي الدولي
الاوبتيما بالنسبه للدوله مثل المملكه
اللي هي منتجه
للمواد خام تقريبا 21% من 19 الى 21%
اللاعب الضريبي
في المملكه حاليا تقريبا
16.16.9% فما زال العبد الضريبي الاجمالي
على القطاع الخاص اقل من متوسط
الدول الاخرى
الحكومه تنظر بشكل يعني مستمر ودوري مع
وزاره الاقتصاد وزاره الماليه وجهه اخرى
بما في ذلك مركز في مركز الحكومه الى كيف
يمكن ان نحسن من ذلك كيف يمكن ان نخفف
الاعباء بماذا الكعبه الالتزام
والامتثال على القطاع الخاص فيما يتعلق
بهذه الشريحه اللي نعتقد انها كبيره حاليا
متعدده من الرسوم والمقابلات الماليه في
دراسه قائمه لمحاوله وضعها بطريقه تساعد
القطاع الخاص لكن لا تزال في اطار تقريبا
الايراد متوسط الايرادات الحاليه بس الان
لا قرار بتغييره حاليا
همم ما في ذكرت اي توجه لاطفاء همم دين
بالفتره القادمه لماذا اهلك ان توضح لنا
بالنسبه
اا نسبه الدين الى الناتج المحل الاجمالي
في السعوديه
اقل من متوسط مجموعه العشرين مجموعه ال20
اذا اخرجنا المملكه تقريبا 85% متوسط
الدائره الناتج من حيث الاجمالي في
المملكه تقريبا
مقفل سنه 22 على تقريبا 24 فاصل تسعه اقل
من 25% فما زال عندنا مجال السؤال هو ليس
زياده الدين او تخفيضه والسؤال هل من
المصلحه هل في عائد انك تستدين اكثر
وبالتالي تستخدم هذه الاموال في عناصر
منتجه في الاقتصاد تحقق لك عائد اكبر اذا
الاجابه نعم سنه اكثر
لكن اخدا في الاعتبار طبعا اوضاع السوق
تكلفه الدين اللي بدات ترتفع من المهم
اداراتها بحصافه مركز اداره الدين عمل عمل
مميز صراحه خلال سنوات السابقه جزء من
الديون اللي تستحق سنه 23 وبعضها سنه 25
في سنه 21 22
سنستمر في ذلك اما لزياده الدين لتمويل
المشاريع زياده الدين لاعاده تمويل همم
ديوان ستستحق في المستقبل او حتى التمويل
البديل همم عندنا خيارات كبيره جدا لتمويل
بعض البنيه التحتيه
المياه همم المعالجه الصرف الصحي وغيرها
من البنيه التحتيه اللي قد نستخدم التمويل
البديل شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا اللقاء
لوزير الماليه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
يحظى الاقتصاد السعوديه بتصنيف ائتمان قوي
من اكبر ثلاث وكالات تصنيف في العالم اسم
في وفيتش
مايا جريديني تستعرض لنا ابرز هذه
التصنيفات وتوقع وتوقعات الوكالات لنمو
الاقتصاد السعودي
لنصار التصنيف السعوديه الائتمانيه من
اكبر 33
موديل
تؤكد على قدره المملكه على تاكلهم مع
تذبذبات اسعار النفط والقدره على ضغط
الماليه العامه وتتوقعون وهو الاقتصاد
السعوديه بمعدل 3.9% في المتوسط للفتره من
2020 الى 2006 2020
لنقارن هذا التصنيف مع دول الكبرى منحت
همم مودي 10 دوله تصنيف الاعلى وهو يتربى
الايه على راسي هل الولايات المتحده
والمانيا وهولندا لكن تصنيف السعوديه عند
اي وان هو اعلى من تصنيف البرتغال
واليونان واسبانيا وايطاليا وهو ممثلا
لتصنيف الصين واليابان
لننتقل الى اس ان في جلوبل حيث انها منحت
السعوديه السابع افضل تصنيف لديها وهو
ايماينس مع نظره مستقبليه ايجابيه اي ان
التصنيف قابل للارتفاع الوكاله شددت على
نمو الاقتصاد غير النقطي في السعوديه
وتوقعت نمو الاقتصادي بسبعه ونصف في المئه
هذا العام
الملفت ان اسال فيه قلوب لم تمنح الولايات
المتحده التصنيف الاعلى عند تريكو الاي
بالمنحتها تصنيفا اقل بدرجه تصنيف
السعوديه لدى اسال في قلوب الاعلام
ايطاليا والبرتغال واليونان والارجنتين
وهو ممثلا لتصنيف بولندا وماليزيا
وكاله فتش عدلات نظرتها السعوديه في ابريل
من مستقره الى ايجابيه مع السادس افضل
تصنيف لديها وهو اي مشدده على اهميه ما
تقوم به المملكه من تنويع للاقتصاد وضبط
الماليه العامه لاسيما تزام ذلك مع ارتفاع
اسعار النفط تصنيف السعوديه لدى فيتش اعلى
من تصنيف عشر دول في مجموعه العشرين على
راسها روسيا والبرازيل والهند واندونيسيا
وتركيا وهو ممثل لتصنيف اليابان
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الختام نذكر بانه الميزانيه
السعوديه للعام 2023 توقعت قائد ب 16
مليار ريال ما يشكل
0.4% من الناتج المحلي وايضا تم الاعلان
عن فائد اعلى من المتوقع في العام 2022
عند 102 مليار ريال بالمقارنه مع توقعات
سابقه عند 90 مليار ريال ريال نهايه هذه
التغطيه الخاصه شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
قصه نجاح توجت بتسجيل السعوديه لاول فائضا
منذ 2013 في ميزانيه العام الجاري جاء
افضل من التوقعات السابقه ليبلغ 100 مليار
ريال و يمثل 2 16 في المئه من النتيجه
المحلي الاجمالي ياتي الفائض على خلفيه
ايرادات بلغت
2434 مليار تشكل الايرادات غير النفطيه
32% منها قبلها نفقات بتروليونان
و132 مليار ريال اما الميزانيه الجديده
لعام 2023
فستشهدوا تحقيقه ثاني فائده على التوالي
عند 16 مليار ريال يمثل 14% من الناتج
المحاليل الاجمالي وفي التفاصيل تقدر
الارادات للعمل مقبل بتر اليونان و 130
مليار ريال مقابل نفقات مثل اليونان و14
مليار يا قلبي ومن ناحيه النمو الاقتصادي
في السعوديه فهو الاسرع بندول مجموعه
العشرين بعد ان جاء عند 8:30 اما خلال
العمل مقبل فمن المتوقع نمو الاقتصاد
بثلاثه فاصله واحد في المئه مدعوما
بالانشطه النفسيه ليرتفع بعدها الى خمسه
و17% في 2024 هذا هو سيسجل التضخم في
السعوديه
626% هذا العام لينخفض الى اثنين فاصله
واحد في المئه في 2003 2020
سياده الدين العام تماشت خلال هذه السنوات
مع التطورات في تحضير الميزانيه العامه
فمحفظه الدين العام تصل اليوم الى 985
مليار
لتقربه 25% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي وقد
ازدادت المديونيه لوزاره الماليه لضمان
بناء علاقه مع اسواق الدين تسمح للم
بالاستدانه في اوقات الحاجه وايضا في
اوقات الرخاء مايا جريديني العربيه
[موسيقى]